what's up guys bang bang bitcoin's up
about 16 to start the year but that's
not the big story the big story is that
there are multiple presidential
candidates that are now coming out in
support of the digital currency I used
to think years and years ago that a
bitcoiner would become president and I
used to describe it in a way where
somebody was going to become president
and happened to hold Bitcoin I didn't
think they'd run on bitcoin as a
campaign topic I just thought Joe Biden
he's the president he owns public
equities so obviously someone who holds
Bitcoin will eventually become president
too but maybe I was wrong we now are
seeing a ton of presidential candidates
come out and actually run with Bitcoin
as one of those campaign topics Robert F
Kennedy Jr not only has come out and
said that he believes Bitcoin is a
freedom technology he also talks about
if he becomes president he will preserve
people's right to actually hold Bitcoin
and he spoke in the Bitcoin conference
and gave a pretty compelling speech on
top of that we solve a vet Rama Swami
who spoke about Bitcoin multiple times
in those conversations he continues to
say that he thinks Bitcoin is important
he believes that the right for people to
own Bitcoin is important and he now is
even taking campaign donations in
Bitcoin then if you jump over to
somebody like Ron DeSantis who's the
governor of Florida he was talking about
Bitcoin and Central Bank digital
currencies in his Twitter spaces with
Elon Musk this past week now not only
has DeSantis come out and actually
banned Central Bank digital currencies
in the State of Florida but he also
believes that Bitcoin is an important
technology and he believes that it is
very important to protect people's right
to own and transact with Bitcoin as well
it reminds me a lot of what we've seen
in Texas where now there are legislation
bills being put forward that will
actually protect people's right to own
Bitcoin and then there are people who
are rumored to actually be running for
president like Miami mayor Francis
Suarez he's been a big proponent of
Bitcoin over the years and now it
appears that if he is to run for
president Bitcoin will be one of the key
pieces as well it's fascinating to watch
all of these different people come out
in support of a technology a technology
that's been adopted by about 15 percent
of the American population but is is
also at the same time under attack by
many of the politicians and Regulators
all around the world now here in the
United States Bitcoin actually seems to
be getting a pretty good Fair shake it
isn't a security and so it's being
treated much more like property in taxes
or some sort of currency or commodity
when it comes to regulation and the
reason why that's important is because
ultimately we want technology to have
the opportunity to flourish we want as
many people to adopt it we want as many
people to build on it now only what we
have to do is we've got to be able to
incentivize the entrepreneurs and the
businesses that are building around this
technology to stay here in the United
States and make sure that Innovation
occurs here now one of the other things
that happened this week which absolutely
is just hilarious and also probably
shocking to many of you is that Peter
Schiff came out and randomly announced
that he is going to go ahead and have
some sort of inscription when it comes
to ordinals he has a piece of art it's a
hand holding a gold bar and now Peter is
trying to sell it now some people may
say this is a cash grab some people
saying that Peter is finally
capitulating regardless of which side of
the debate you end up on it's always
funny to me to see people who have been
ordered critics of Bitcoin for years and
years and years eventually they pay
attention they start learning and they
all realize that Bitcoin is not going
anywhere Bitcoin is an important
technology Bitcoin will continue to be
valuable and they all become bitcoiners
welcome Peter Schiff we've been waiting
for you I hope all of you have a great
weekend and I'll talk to you all next
week